[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh dan orlovsky
the great analyst for the mothership nfl
live continues daily throughout the
entire offseason at 4 eastern on espn
catch dan with adam schafter marcus
spears mina kimes
laura rutledge 4 pm eastern daily
on espn dan thanks for joining us did
the cowboys have
a great day yesterday huh the cowboys
did not uh dak prescott did dak prescott
dak prescott's family did um but this
was a big time swing and miss for the
cowboys i think that they took a
calculated risk
you know they tried to be patient and
patient and patient and
didn't want to do something like the
rams or the eagles did
but man that is a ton
of money to give dak prescott what
should the expectation
level b for cowboy fans this year
oh this year at least uh you're talking
second round of the playoffs
sniffing your nfc championship game you
know like
here's here's this is what my comment is
with this and it's the old
saying to much is given much is expected
this is why i was very cautious
of giving dak prescott a ton of money or
second most quarterback money
it's going to impact your football team
and we can't
now sit here and say well he's really
good
but the expectations stay the same the
expectations
have to be elevated not only
individually hey when our left tackles
out
we still have to win the game on the
road against the new york jets because
they stink
or when we don't have amari cooper we
still got to play good at the position
because you're supposed to be in a
difference maker when it comes to the
finances
um it's a bad division i still have to
wait to see what happens in washington
at the quarterback spot if they got a
quarterback that i thought was a good
player
orion fitzpatrick i think that i would
favor them to win the division
because i think dallas still has issues
defensively offensive line wise and
overpaid at tailback other than that
and good luck good luck trying to fix
those over the next four years
well that's my point with all of this is
i don't like
zeke's contract the offensive line is
not what it once was
and you got guys got paid up there the
defense is
one of the most overrated units in in
football right now
i'm not sure about mike mccarthy i mean
and jerry's not you know jerry's what 79
years of age dan
like there's no rebuild he he thinks he
reloads here but
i i'm with you people might put the
giants ahead of the cowboys going into
the next season
i would if but here's my thing i need to
know where saquon's health is i said
this
five minutes ago uh if if you gave me
ryan fitzpatrick with washington
and they gave me and you gave me an
offensive lineman that was a
a quality offensive lineman there and a
receiver outside of mclaurin
i'll take washington if you told me that
saquon barkley was completely healthy
that leonard williams is going to get
franchise tagged
in new york and you've got a receiver to
replace golden tate
i'd take that uh new york over them
because i think that
they're a better run football
organization i believe in martin mayhew
in washington i think that they're
better coached football teams
and they're they're a healthier team won
the 53.
the roster over doesn't have the stars
potentially
but it's healthier damn last year with
dak healthy they were two and three
yeah they were two and three and in the
first half of those games drew for four
touchdowns and had four turnovers
then everything hit the fan but like it
wasn't like they were playing
awesome football when he was healthy
they were just so
down so much that the stats got padded
he'd do it for a thousand yards last
year down for two when they were down
by more than two scores so i get it it's
a day of celebration for dak prescott
but don't kid yourselves thinking that
this
is the difference between mediocrity of
20 years and now being a super bowl
legit contender
the other thing that hasn't been
factored in i don't think nationally by
the media is dak is coming off a broken
ankle
he didn't lose anything at the
bargaining table dan if you came off
knee surgery
or you came off a broken ankle i'd feel
more confident you coming off knee
surgery than a broken ankle
uh i i don't know if you ever had a
broken ankle but
at that position and i do ask him to run
a little bit here
it doesn't feel like that's being played
up enough
yeah i mean i i broke my ankle my last
the last game of my 2011 you're on the
road against jacksonville
and it lingered for the rest of my
career um it wasn't as severe as dax now
he's a significantly better athlete all
that stuff and prayer was
i mean we have to realize though too no
off season last year
and people can tell me it didn't hurt go
watch the games they were very average
to below average offensively in the
first half then it became a
complete throw it everywhere against
prevent defense
no off season last year this year no off
season again
and you're you're gonna have you're
gonna have to do it in the midst of
rehab
okay um you're gonna have pieces on your
football team because there's still
three million dollars over the cap
so who's going to take the hit someone
is going to have to get
moved or take a hit or something like
that you're going to have to develop
some of your young players and so
the fact that you're going into a second
straight year without an off season
with an injury you don't know what he's
going to look like in a game to get him
in the preseason
and you're probably going to be hesitant
to play him a ton
we're talking to dan arlovsky the espn
nfl analyst a couple other things here
i think you tweeted uh the silence is
deafening with russell wilson
um yeah maybe i'm paraphrasing here what
what do you think is happening or
what do you expect to happen yeah it
reminds me of the carson one situation
in philadelphia like that fired coach
new head coach nothing getting said
russell hasn't said anything it's the
easiest time ever to say something
right and he's only throwing gasoline on
the fire i i think there's a lot of
layers to this dan i think it starts
with russell wilson once out of seattle
right now
i think russell wilson has a vision 15
plus years from now to be the magic
johnson of the nfl the first guy to go
from player to like
big time kind of brand business type of
guy
i i think he realizes that that that's
not going to happen in seattle for him
um i believe that he wants to go to a
bigger market nine years really good
football never gotten an mvp
vote okay really never really thoroughly
been into the conversation
up until this season i think he's tired
of playing for a defensive minded head
coach
um i think he wants to be the focal
point of a football team both
you know uh literally and schematically
so to speak um and i think that
i i think that there's a little bit of a
heat check you know
i i say this all the time quarterbacks
have egos and it's why they become who
they
are um but i think he's going i think
i'm great
and i think i'm powerful um and he's and
he's right
let me find out if seattle sees it the
same way let's find out if seattle views
me the way
same way i view me and i think seattle's
starting to warm to the idea you know
what russ
we're not gonna play your game we're not
we're not gonna let you be bigger than
us that's why they sent out those
letters
and he's not on it come on come on i
think pete carroll is going nope
not gonna let you play that way yeah the
letter they sent out to season ticket
holders talked about dk metcalf
and tyler lockett and they somehow left
out a
future hall of famer in russell wilson
exactly
yeah no message being sent there i think
it comes down to ego i think it's pete
carroll versus russell wilson
and you know last man standing and it's
going to be pete carroll
but if one you know now the cowboys are
off the list
i wonder if russ expands the list a
little bit dan because
i can't see the bears offering anything
that seattle's gonna go oh okay
you know maybe the raiders you know i
get derek carr
and something the saints i don't see
that happening if i'm russ
i really want out i think i got to
expand my uh
my wish list here yeah you'd have to i
mean it would be silly not to include in
new york and miami right if you really
want it out because they
you know those are two teams that have
multiple first-round picks in this year
and
next year's draft with the jets included
in that so you you obviously want to
that
i think seattle has to ask themselves
two major questions
do we believe that we can win this way a
super bowl because
they've got multiple experiences they
did it and won the super bowl when
russell was
cheap and then they paid them and they
haven't been able to replicate that
so they might sit back and be like you
know what we tried it this way it did
not work
we actually want to go back to doing it
in a financially
um flexible way and the second thing
would be this
how do they replace them how do they
replace it because you can't just go
what will trade you
you've got to find either the player or
the capital to go replace
the quarterback position whether it's a
rookie or something like that i only
would say this
caveat with the chicago one his brother
lives in chicago and his brother works
in chicago
and they're desperate we as human beings
make stupid decisions when we're
desperate
and you could you could take chicago and
go
listen matt naggy and ryan pace if you
don't get russell you're fired you're
more than likely fired for next year
so give us your next three ones and i
think that's something that seattle
would have to find worthy for
consideration
why is it that we love the unknown at
the quarterbacking position
that we did this with deshaun watson
where teams talk themselves out of
desean watson because they go
well you know we've we've seen
everything from him
we like the unknown like mitchell
trubisky or daniel jones
and it feels like we're doing that with
zach wilson who was
he had to beat out somebody to start
this past season
whereas justin fields has been there in
front of us and it feels like
we might be treating him the way we did
to sean watson explain this logic to me
when it comes to quarterbacks in the
draft
yeah two things uh when you go to the
grocery store there's a reason why the
candy bars are at the checkout aisle and
they got
shiny wrappers because it catches our
vision that's a legit thing you know
like
and i feel like we sometimes do that
with quarterbacks shiny object i gotta
get it i gotta get it i gotta get it it
looks cool
and we've we've kind of fallen into that
trap in the nfl
um while while we've seen the infusion
of athleticism
at that quarterback spot come into the
nfl we still
scout the quarterback position backwards
we look at defensive ends wide receivers
offensive lineman linebackers physically
first then mentally because that's
what's necessary
there's a certain requisite size speed
shape to play those positions that's
secondary for the quarterback spot
the physical attributes for the
quarterback will always be
secondary you have to think fast you
have to play
fast you have to have remarkable
leadership you have to have incredible
study habits
you have to have great vision um you
have to have
the intellect to handle all that
information and then be physically good
but just because you're physically good
if you're mentally poor it's going to
catch up to you
and i think that zach wilson's that guy
that you see like physically so
impressive
we've got to figure out where he is
intellectually um
and i think that people are looking at
justin fields and going
well your receiver was open a lot that
ryan day designed for you and i'm like
so what like that's the job of the coach
to get people open
and then the job of the quarterback is
throw it to him i've got
multiple examples of justin fields going
from the second to the third
you know uh pick or read when it comes
to that stuff
but at the end of the day um patrick
mahomes has opened our eyes to a
different
type of quarterback that we want that we
crave
that we think we can get zach wilson
looks a lot like him
always great to talk to you thank you
dan i always learned something you can
watch uh more of dan
uh on the morning with greenie on getup
and also uh espn nfl live thank you
buddy we appreciate your time
thank you